-It's been such a delight
this holiday week
to have our old friend
Fred Armisen
back with us on the drums.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, we've been
close friends for a long time.
And, sadly, you know,
we connect the most
when we see each other at work
because it allows us
this time to talk.
And as we go into
the holiday season,
I heard you backstage
saying to people --
because obviously every family
has different
holiday traditions.
We wake up first thing Christmas
morning, we unwrap presents.
But I heard you have
a non-present
Christmas morning
holiday tradition.
-Yeah, this goes back to,
you know,
when I was a kid
with my family and stuff,
and we used to just go out
and, you know, as a group...
-As a family?
-...as a family
to New York City.
And what we would do is like...
we would just point
to, you know --
Like, if there was
a Santa Claus or something,
we would just point
to the Santa Claus on the corner
and just sort of just
stand there for a while,
just kind of like...
[ Laughter ]
And then we'd move on..
So, like, we'd go by the tree
and we'd find, you know,
one of the tourists there
and just like, point to them,
and...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so you wouldn't --
It wasn't
just that you pointed at Santas.
You would just point
at different things
over the course of the day?
-Yeah, just like in the morning.
It was kind of like festive
because, you know,
it was like a festive
feeling around it, and...
-Now, a lot of people
think pointing is rude.
Do you, uh,
do you buy into that?
-I don't buy into that at all.
-Yeah.
-Uh, I find it not rude.
And the way we did it was
very sort of Christmassy.
Like...
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-So I'm a tourist.
Just hypothetically,
I'm a tourist,
and I'm going
about myself, and I --
and how many of there
are in your group?
-Four. So there's four of us.
-So I turn, and then I see
a family of four...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And do you say --
do you say anything?
-No, because then, like,
throughout the rest
of the Christmas Day,
we sort of move on
to another family
or, like, to just workers.
-What's the longest
you sort of silently pointed
at someone?
-Like a minute.
-Yeah.
-That's a long time.
-You know, it is
once you're doing it.
And when you're a kid,
you know, you were a baby,
so it's, like, hard to hold,
you know, hold your...
-Oh, so the hard part
wasn't how awkward it was.
It was just keeping your arm up.
-You'd be surprised. Yeah.
-That's really --
-But as you get older,
as a teen, you know,
there's, like,
more energy behind it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Merry Christmas, buddy.
-Merry Christmas.